forse non molti sanno che
la maggior parte dei fondi pubblici
dell'unione europea
sono destinati all'agricoltura.
ultimamente si è parlato moltissimo di questo tema,
per tutte le proteste
che gli agricoltori hanno fatto da Bruxelles
fino all'italia,
ma la verità è che questi fondi
sono sempre stati dati a pioggia.
oggi noi chiediamo invece di
applicare quello che la
commissione ha iniziato a fare col green deal,
e cioè dare fondi
solamente a quelle aziende agricole che si
impegnano ad avere
standard più elevati di benessere animale,
standard più elevati dal punto di Vista
ambientale e per la salute
delle persone.
vediamo anche un'altra cosa, però importantissima,
una moratoria entro 2000 e 30 su nuovi allevamenti
intensivi. in Europa ce ne sono troppi,
ci sono troppi animali
confinati in questi allevamenti
e il loro impatto è veramente devastante.
per saperne di più
sulla nostra campagna per le elezioni europee
potete visitare
vote for animals, punto i. t.